we are learning the name of a woman shot
and killed during a new year's eve
robbery happening at fashion show mall
she was 66 year old clarice yamaguchi
from hawaii 8 news now reporter sally
jeremiah has been digging the story
joining us live outside the mall with
those details
brian the corner says yamaguchi was shot
in the back of her neck when arriving to
the mall and now many local businesses
here say they are still left in shock
tonight
police say yamaguchi and her husband
were robbed while getting out of their
car jason respec owner of the ssr vegas
scooter slingshot rentals caught the
direction the vehicles were leaving the
mall on his surveillance cameras as well
as capture the bmw with tinted windows
respect says it's a sign of the times we
are living in we're just living in those
days and we just need to help each other
out and watch each other's back because
it can happen anywhere at any time
police say it was part of a crime spree
by 20-year-olds jaisani carter and
jordan ruby detectives say they are
responsible for the murder at fashion
show mall and a second at palace station
as of right now they are only booked on
one charge of open murder and charges of
attempted robbery
back out live both 20 year olds are
expected in court tomorrow as for
yamaguchi's family they were too sad to
speak to us tonight reporting live sally
haramio live local now